they signal V for victory but these
five-year-olds don't really know what it
means it was a common gesture in the
revolution nine years ago now it's being
used as Libya is mired in conflict once
again this school in Tripoli has been
hit three times by rockets these
children are caught in the middle of a
fight between government forces and
those led by warlord Khalifa Haftar and
they are learning about death and
destruction fifty percent of the 450
pupils at this school are said to be
suffering from trauma with war
destruction and indiscriminate shelling
this is an extremely hard and difficult
psychological impact on the children you
can see many are completely broken and
they have no desire to continue their
education it's not a good time to be
young in Libya life is precarious the
economy is suffering and the staples of
life have become luxuries and once they
finish school the opportunities are
limited to us the sky's the limit but
when you kind of live in Libya that
limit is kind of you know decreased more
and more relieving they prefer to take
their chances abroad then stay and face
unemployment and hardship at home for a
hundred thousand students at Tripoli
University just half of them are
expected to find a job after graduation
many have left their studies to fight
because the government did not give to
the youth the opportunity to study in
these hard times it's destroyed the
future of half of young men I wish I
could leave who doesn't hope for that
when a country cannot guarantee you a
job abroad they show appreciation that
you're educated there are no official
statistics of how many of the young
educated are leaving but everyone agrees
it's not an insignificant number next to
achieving a lasting peace here the
biggest challenge is going to be how to
stop the departure flow of Libya's young
talent before it becomes a flood at this
intellectual forum they're trying to do
that by helping people set up their own
businesses
you feel like there is no hope Olivia
and a lot of them are trying to get
abroad in various you know departments
and at various specialities but it's
it's very worrying because they don't
see a future in Libya when Moammar
Gaddafi was overthrown as leader in 2011
people the young in particular were
promised a bright new future nine years
on and the children of Libya are still
waiting
Tony Berkeley al Jazeera Tripoli